John and Fiona Prine graciously invited
us into their Nashville home our day
began with a chat in the family living
room when we discussed Prime's
decades-long career and the success of
his latest album the tree of forgiveness
so how does it feel to get Grammy
nominations now it's been 46 years since
the first time really great I mean it
does you know I didn't expect that I
don't know where I get another Grammy
nomination I didn't even know there have
been that long step for a record yeah I
thought it was like six years or
something you know my family reminded me
they hadn't done my 13 years what when
you got the first nomination though 46
years ago what did that feel like that
was pretty neat whisper artist of the
year it was the Eagles I was talking to
somebody last night about the Eagles
Loggins and Messina the group America
the fur horse with no name and Harry
Chapin and America won whenever I see
the guys from the Eagles over the years
you know they lament that like you know
we shared every day yeah but that was
for the first Grammy nomination I didn't
I got nominated over the years but I
never won one until the messengers and I
guess that was 92 I was my first Grammy
I took home and people always say it's
it's an honor just to be nominated and
it's really nice to do win yeah so you
won't win yeah we actually I find that
as far as all the publicity behind it
and everything the day after the Grammy
said you know people don't know where
you go like you know she took the big
prize oh there were nobody you know
really guys that actually won it or just
got nominated so it's pretty good yeah
yeah but and you've been nominated for
three big door prizes I have yeah did
you know when you wrote this album that
that when you put this album out that
what happened hey no idea
I mean to cut me by surprise really I
mean my records always
generally they think it well-received
you know the press is always usually
happy to see one and my fans that come
to the shows their static over a new
record because I don't put them out
there often but this one just started
running and didn't stop
so I had to just figure a way to keep up
with it you know it's been a wild year
yeah tell me about the the process for
this album well ok initially our son
Jody who runs oh boy records now and my
wife Fiona who's met he's managing me
they came to me and said they said more
or less well actually literally they
said it's time to make a record and went
what are you talking about I just made
what was 13 years ago and they said we
booked time it's to do away with Dave
Cobb and they knew that one who work
with David Marin before and we talked
about it I said well when I get 10 songs
together I'll give you a call and they
booked time with him and they booked me
a suite at the Omni Hotel down downtown
Nashville the one that's hooked up to
the Country Music Hall of Fame they know
I like to go there any time somebody
comes to town we have a guest at the
house I always drag him down there
because it's a fun place to go and so
they booked me into a suite and I
arrived with three guitars I look like
Howard Hughes ten boxes of unfinished
lyrics I didn't know I had unfinished
lyrics I just know I had scraps of paper
somewhere so these ten boxes of lyrics
there was two bell boys and took me up
to the room with all the guitars in the
boxes and they Fiona and Jolie knew that
I operate better out of a hotel room
than I do at home you know at home I got
all kinds of excuses I could come up
with it but like I I'm a late night
person I like to stay up and that's fine
I do my best work at night you know got
the TV
and my guitar is going and you know and
I can write down these ideas I get so I
had they had they gave me uh it was like
when you get a hotel you're gonna you
have to going down into the studio so
you better have some songs so I had more
than I thought I had the unfinished once
were just a matter of sitting down and
doing a verse here reverse there I came
up with two or three new ones I was up
there in the hotel these ideas have been
going around for years and nobody ever
told me to sit down and write oh yeah so
that was the process of the beginning
before we go do you did anybody in the
neighboring rooms call the front desk
and say Howard uses in the next room no
the guy's delivery you got 24 hour room
service you know they they come up there
and hear me banging away on the guitar
and delivering food to me you know
different hours and there's a nice staff
down there I felt comfortable there it
was a very great place to put me because
I wouldn't have got that work don't here
at the house and so so you're what
you're there with a tape recorder your
guitars and I mean are you recording
what you're writing or you are you like
how is it working there in the hotel
room
the last thing I do is commit to tape
usually you know I may just to see if I
got the right I'm um real picky about
syllables like I like enough it's like
the Chuck Berry school song right you
wanna have a syllable for every note you
know or at least the word has to hit you
here right I mean I can have the right
word for what the lion and her song is
supposed to mean but if it doesn't sound
right to me I'll pick a really goofy
word just to throw in there one that
sounds good
you know I figure they can figure out
what it means to lay right
yeah don't have to supply what the song
means you just have to write the darn
thing right right
and sometimes they'll stuff entire
meaning into an enchilada
this too that's a story for another for
another time
the so so you emerge from the from the
hotel room and then you go directly
right to the a week later I was in the
studio and in between that time I didn't
once I got a hotel I was out of the work
mode
yeah you know but by that time I was
excited about going there just studio
because I actually did have 10 songs 10
songs I liked and I didn't know that so
if my family wouldn't have pushed me
into it I was still been just walking
around going now I'm a collector maybe
next year
yeah I guess your songs because they
have those attention to detail scraps
that you've picked up from here and
there it feels like you're always
writing songs you're always listening so
that is that right or no well I don't
consider it work you know I mean I'll
get some my best ideas behind it
steering wheel rather than behind the
guitar I think my I think it's all got
to do with my idea of of work you know
my when I first started writing songs
that was a my getaway
it was my from get away from the world
and from my job and everything I'd go on
me write a song but now it's my job so
it feels I get to I you know you have to
make an appointment with somebody in
order to co-write with Herman and I
prefer to co-write we're just friends
that way if you don't get a song I'm not
wasting your day yeah yeah my favorite
thing is to go with lunch
you know that's usually I'll sit down
write with a co-writer I'll buy two
lines and go you know because we can
waste a lot of time going to yeah is
that how it is with it with a song that
you that you you work on it step away
from it work you I mean how does that
process work when it comes down to
getting the lines you talked about the
rhyme but is it well some of the people
that go
my brother Pat McLaughlin I love writing
with Pat because we sit there and like
have conversation and all of a sudden
you're shy relying for the song and I'll
come back with something like an answer
you know and when it works we get into
it but the thing I like is I don't like
sitting there feeling like we're forced
to come up with something new you want
what you ultimately want is a song that
that your wire saying forever I tell
people when people ask me for advice
about song writing I was just saying
make sure you write something like
because the works thing that happened is
it becomes a head and everywhere you
going every day your life you'll be
expected to sing that side so don't
write something goofy for like that you
know go number one because it might be
number one and tag you're it
yeah you've been singing songs that you
wrote in the late sixties early
seventies I know and luckily I really
liked the songs yeah I don't probably do
know they've ever done so without
singing the song Sam stone or hello in
there paradise I think I sing those
every every time I do show I don't they
ever leave map let me ask you about
hello in there and that first album now
that you mentioned it particularly hello
in there at an angel from Montgomery
these are songs you were how old when
you wrote those 22 yeah 21 22
so you're 22 21
writing stories about an old woman and
hello in there is about people who are
much older where was that coming from
how does it turn how does somebody in
their early 20s know about I mean
growing up I was real close to my
grandparents on both sides they just
treated me like I was you know I don't
know that got sent my for Christmas tree
you know and and like because of them
when I meet other
they got newspaper routers out there and
meet other elderly people like I felt an
affinity for him you know that found
that if you talk to him a little bit
then they'll start telling they got
loads of stories to tell and that kind
of came natural to me too
to write that song it was what it was a
matter of I was too inexperienced to
know I was what I was doing you know
there was no boundaries and I was
writing the songs for myself I wasn't
writing them thinking I was and we
understand another stage and sing my
songs for anybody here and that all
happened within a two-year period that
all changed when when you then become
John prime which happens pretty quickly
do you then have to kind of unlearn
being John Prine to get back to the
place where you're just writing songs
for yourself you that's a good question
when I go to write anymore luckily I got
I mean I have this I have a never ending
thing of crazy ideas and if I dig far
enough some of those might be really
good much you know but they're always
there like even if I don't write for a
couple of years when I go to write if I
spend enough time with it there's
something that there's something down
there always you know it's very rare
that if I actually take the time to look
into it the I'm trying to explain as my
thoughts are not my own I have no
control over you know if I can't just
let it go abandoned abandoned
they'll be lot of junk there and
there'll be a gym you know and if there
is it's like one thing leads to another
good idea and you you follow it long
enough hello and there was a real it was
a real gift oh you're right that song I
mean the melody was especially I knew
less at that time about playing the
guitar then if somebody would teach me
one new song if it had one or two chords
I would go off and write
a song with those chords rather than
learn somebody else's song you know it
was so amazing to me so I took every
guitar chord I knew at the time and that
became the melody that alone I mean I'm
more or less to him in a hat and played
him in that order
and luckily they came out really good
and and off that same album souvenirs
you know that's a deep song and you
wrote it in a car waited to the club the
fifth peg I thought I'd played there
three Thursday's in a row for $0.50 a
person and then and they gave me a
quarter and they kept the other quarter
and I thought the same 12 people were
gonna be there and I figured the
probably expected me to come up with
another song you know said oh I'm seeing
the same old songs like Sam's darling
hello in there and that and I wrote it
for one new song so I could later on and
when I got to the club I realized I had
the melody in my head but to me the
melody sounds like jazz he said like
about 14 guitar chords and like a big
little song there's not that and I went
in the men's room and put my guitar
around my neck and stir from the mirror
and I played the song it was like three
chords the same three chords I played in
the Paradise there's nothing yet and I
just went up and sang the song for the
first time you know it was a pretty one
stuck over these years well and that's a
song where you know the line
I hate graveyards and old pawn shops yes
they always bring me tears I mean that's
that feels like it's a you obviously had
that thought through the course of your
life and then suddenly it arrives into a
song yeah turns out I love foreign jobs
yeah that I like to go see other
people's junk yeah
with the graveyard thing you mentioned
wet and Sam stone I heard you once
talked about it and you talked about the
the broken radio that's in the song and
it is that how it works you you descend
so describe the broken radio where that
comes from it came from a couple of
different sources my father loved to uh
he didn't watch much TV and he kept this
old black Zenith radio in the kitchen
and he would prop the window up open
weather so he faced it towards the south
we grew up in western suburb of Chicago
he would face the radio of towards the
south to pick up WS Emmer we had a
really good country station in in
Chicago as well w JJ D and that's how he
listened to his country music and that
black Zenith radio had gotten dropped on
the floor a few times it had a bunch of
a black electricians tape around it I
just remember if you if I wanted to sit
and talk with him and listen to country
music and he'd be drinking beer and pour
me an orange soda
he talked politics with me and I'm six
years old and he took me to his favorite
bar ever once about everybody knew me
they'd give me a necklace for the
pinball machine and everything and I'm
getting away from you a question no good
okay so and I will post men and we'd
listen to the radio while we were short
in our mail and the morning and it was a
hook to a really long extension cord
which people trip over so that radio got
to UM beat up on the floor couple of
times and had the same tape on that my
dad's radio death
and okay so now I'm remembering exactly
where I got the idea for Sam stone I
used to read all the magazines at
lunchtime and I deliver them to the
people that try and make sure you can
get catch up on you know and stuff and I
was reading
Time magazine and a book in there that
had just come out the title it was
yellow bad bug down radio and
such a great sound to it
you know phonetically and I remembered
that and and I started messing with the
image of broken radios and I always
sucked in an angel from Montgomery I'd
used to work rodeo well young lady was a
great word if you look into it it's in
loads of songs there's just a great
sounding word yeah but broken radios and
then that kind of fed into the story
about this bachelor and I've uh pretty
much the whole thing I'm a male vibe and
I went home and I couldn't find paper
right uh and my wife at the time I'd
gone to work and she left her the card
boy from a brand new set of pantyhose
and I wrote Sam stone on the back of
three of those cardboard things and just
so I wouldn't forget but it was a pretty
long thing to keep I mean I vote never
pretty much always walk down the mail
route same with hello in there you got
loads of time on your hands
oh yeah you know you know you're on the
right Street and you've been there just
yesterday putting the mail in there so
you got your free day the reason I was
interested in the broken radio is it's
sometimes when I've heard you describe
your songs you'll grab one of those
beautiful specific images yeah it feels
like sometimes the the image is the
thing around which the pearl of the song
is built is that is that yeah you know
because it takes something like one
strong image to pull the rest of it out
and then from there on in it's more of a
craft you know but you gotta have that
one kind of burning coal to keep looking
at it or keep keeps coming up in the
song and that's what draws the other
stuff out yeah
and so now you've been inducted into the
Songwriters Oh a bank what does that
feel like well it's really great I mean
about
years ago I was inducted into the
National Songwriters Hall of Fame which
was really great for me because like I
said I was always a big fan country
music and my dad's love for it that's my
dad and my mom's love for country music
my mom used to sing it while she was
cooking a snare and my legacy my dad
would be listening to it on the radio
all the time and to being inducted into
that one was was really great because I
had a bunch of friends in there and to
find out I'm got a bunch of new friends
and the Songwriters Hall of Fame I mean
I'm in there with Gershwin and all those
all those people about you know it's
like it's really great yeah and do you
feel like does it feel like payoff for a
long for a lot of hard work does it feel
what's the emotion other thing then hey
this is neat well I'm getting I'm
getting live you know stuff from there's
accumulated it's for your whole career
you know I hardly I always stayed away
from the word career I never was that
good when somebody would go oh my career
I would think wow am I glad I don't have
way I just have work yeah and but now
when you look back on it feels like a
career you know I mean for you I've been
doing this 47 years 48 years oh my god
and any other job you'd be a fool to
still be working after 48 years but it
gets better each day really you know I
have a lot of fun on the road this year
they've got a great band that all I have
to do is show up and make sure I can
sing that day yeah you talked about your
grandparents and you said with them they
they had you just ask them questions and
they would tell you stories are they are
your grandparents where you got your
storytelling my agent my mom was a great
storyteller
my mom had nicknames for everybody
hearing her
in her town she grew up in Paradise my
dad spent part of his time there but he
was from the same area but my mother
actually was born and raised in Paradise
Kentucky and everybody in the town had a
weird nickname or a story about him you
know
feeling used to go with me too we used
to go my family reunions and the closer
we got to a union time the more my
mother would remember she got around her
sisters they all had different stories
about the same people with the same
nicknames and she was a natural-born
storyteller my dad wasn't after we got a
couple of beers and they could tell our
stories do ya your most recent album
when you talked about when you write
about getting to heaven you talk about
meeting your mother sisters reconnecting
with that family
you also have pictures of them when you
play right don't you have pictures on my
dad on my table yeah yeah a lot of
pictures of my boys and my mother's
picture and I just keep my on the table
with all my pics and my bottles are
wired are you said I used to smoke on
stage and they'd bring I used to come
out with a six-pack they put a stool out
on stage and they mistakenly put the
stool in front of the microphone like it
was gonna sit around like a books there
the stool was for my six-pack in the
ashtray and before and every song I'd
like up I was taught a story
I put the cigarette in the ashtray and
I'd sing the song and the cigarette be
gone by the time I got done so I'd fire
up in the other way so now I drink wire
instead instead of beer in between songs
and the wires also my cigarette yeah
you're not smoking you're not smoking
anymore you've had cancer twice it has
had those experiences changed the way
you viewed all of the accolades you've
gotten this year the Grammy nominations
the Songwriters Hall of Fame and also
success of this album has led to an
outpouring of people who I mean they
just heap praise upon you does that what
does that feel like just what does that
feel like first of all having all of
that actually I mean because I've been
doing this too long
it feels pretty darn good I mean 10
years ago or however many years ago I
might have shied away from that that
might have been a little too much for me
to take in at one time but this whole
this whole thing this this last record
the tree of forgiveness it's been a
family project and so when I think I've
had a little bit too much of this this
this really glorified stuff I remember
that my family has never experienced
this before so that gets really good
thing at the end of the day it's all
about the family yeah well that's what
strikes me about you write about the
family in the tree of forgiveness the
family was what got you into the hotel
room to write the tree of forgiveness a
family project with oh boy records
exactly you've got the pictures when you
play you take them on the road I got the
pictures to prove I have a favorite
family is wrapped through this whole it
really is I mean I couldn't couldn't a
wouldn't have done this you know without
my family let me go back to asking you
about the about the cancer that would is
that does that do you reflect on it
differently given that you struggled
through that twice yeah I mean there's
part of me that's grateful for the
lesson the cancer teaches you you know
it you can't help but go through
something like that no matter what kind
of individual you are what kind of
background you got you can't help but go
through a bout of cancer and come out
the other end and have the doctor say we
don't need to see you anymore you don't
have to come here and he can't go
through that without feeling a little
bit no matter how much you thought you
enjoyed life you just enjoy just that
much more it puts a another little glaze
on everything
and to go through it twice the second
time was as though I almost felt like I
was telling the doctor where this job
was you know what he said would you want
me to do I said I want you to go in
there and cut it out come back to me and
say John you don't have cancer anymore
that's exactly what what they did and
the second time I was really lucky day
because of the the heaven cancer before
going for so many checkups they saw the
second cancer coming way down to vote
you know they would never saw that if I
hadn't been going for chest x-rays over
six months and stuff so when they did
that one they didn't have to do any
radiation or chemo the second one they
cut it out and it was gone was it tell
me about your you're retraining regimen
before you went back on the road because
you tore a lot now and and just describe
what you went through to retrain to
build it well the second cancer I had
was a guy my left lung tagging out and I
got together with this this buddy who
was a trainer when we love spending time
together we couldn't talk enough and he
also like play the guitar part like an
amateur guitar player but he really
enjoyed asking me questions about
playing and doing my stuff and writing
and stuff and he came back and I had
worked with him earlier to try and just
keep myself healthy and lose a few
pounds and when I got the lung cancer I
got that cut out he came to my house and
he had seen me do shows before so he
made me run up and down my step the
flight of stairs three times and he
throw a guitar around my neck make me
sing two songs like when I was our
breath and he did all this I wouldn't
breath onstage and I thought that was
going to all that fellas in boot camp
there's nothing I said how did I get
back to doing this you know I became a
singer so I could be lazy and you know
I'm running up and down stairs
did you always sing the same two songs
or did you know he lets the songs you
would tell me the songs you wanted to
hear
next we made our way into the study John
and his wife Fiona who is also his
manager shared some of the artifacts at
the singers career because their shows
so to record these books I've never seen
read
I have reads aloud she's probably read
everything there I read that I read
music biographies that I start in the
middle I've never started if I start in
the middle and I get three or four
chapters then I might go back to the
first page and see where the person was
born great see if they're interesting
enough to be worth invest
by just that good stories he likes
Archie comics Archie comics I'm a big
Archie fan
where did that come from child I like
that I like I like the pretty colors
comics but I got getting them I get them
in the mail at the end of the month it's
kind of nice and heavier dress - Johnny
find age 72 and your simple about
getting up fresh air to convey but you
know it's just kind of nice you know you
mentioned Johnny prime that's what your
mother used to call you right yeah yeah
so Fiona tell me the difference between
Johnny prime and John prime I think
Johnny prime is a little guy mm-hmm yeah
but that Johnny prime is still around oh
my gosh childlike innocence you know I
mean things that you you know he loves
Christmas he loves his family Archie
comics you know simple things not
necessarily childish things but simple
things this is late to January yeah yeah
and there's this Christmas tree is that
Christmas that Christmas tree is up year
round it's gonna it's gonna be is the
first year in this aspect I've heard in
other houses where the trees didn't stay
in really good shape I kept him up as a
bachelor mm-hmm and it's afraid to treat
living pledge was that your own
innovation or had you read somewhere
that lemon pledge you'd turn it into a
flammable rocket fires we go up to
Christmas yeah yeah what are the the 45s
they're hanging well I think they even
look prettier this was the first oh boy
Oh
warped yeah John put up this was when he
first started to a boy records right yep
when did oh boy start 1981 we we started
with this record with I saw Mommy
Kissing Santa Claus and silver bells on
the other side the only place you could
give him was a Ernest Tubb record store
down lower Broadway they're in the mail
we'd sell them in the mail and we got a
really good response to initial e so I
ended up making an album for oh boy we
our fans really helped us out they get
the record company started there
everybody supported us the people that
come see us live we leave those 3x5
cards and they'd thought about this
before ever the air that we had this
whole network of people we knew we could
sell records to they were some with some
checks that before I went in the studio
and told me the next record way we
thought here's my this is the first show
of the of the tree of forgiveness tour
wasn't really us in case you get hungry
bacon eggs anyway this is gonna stay
this is the perennial Chris usually
getting lemon played um yeah he's good
as a Betty Veronica book back
Oh Archie comics sent me a bunch of
books like this it's the art oh so it
sort of just pictures of the girls oh
okay yeah I have to watch who I say that
way like because I mentioned her like
hot dogs with mustard and I got your
supplier of both the hot dogs and the
mustard you just mentioned people said
to you do you take do you take your own
mustard on the road with you yeah okay
yeah my bag in the flame yeah yeah
usually I carry a tuba Coleman semester
everything and and and have you always
done that and need have it with you
right yeah
I'd also imagine when you're on the road
I know this from being on the road with
politics all the time when you're on the
road it's it can be kind of lonely or
you know you're unfamiliar places so if
you surround yourself right with
familiar stuff you just devote just have
to step out there yeah yeah I mean we
know your way in the dark around the
hotel rooms
you said wondering if you'd be staying
at there's a song what's the hardest
part about being on the road as much as
you are well I would say over the years
the hardest part was missing your family
like missing my kids growing up in that
but now the pre owners married you me
meet her out there together so I never
have to tell
Laozi the hotel was she says oh yeah
yeah we had the hotel rooms are getting
nicer and the dressing rooms are getting
nicer do it deserves it yeah do you
notice the different classes of hotels
you know if it has if you don't have to
unwrap the cup in the bathroom you're
staying in a slightly nicer oh yeah but
that's the kind of stuff I throw in the
bag and take with me great are you a
hoarder John Bryan no no I used
everything I steal you know I bow I like
taking silverware from Mojo's
watch out I come home and feel fine it's
wrapped up in the napkin there's cheap
no I order something for myself I always
tell them that there's two dining so
they'll send an extra set of silverware
I take that one put on my suitcase and
then use the other one you're always
ready yeah you never know what's gonna
happen you know I take that mistake
there and have no silverware close the
curtains well that was actually from
Georgetown DC when the first place is
worried that took out for Steve
government may was playing the old it's
the name of it now so do it yeah and we
used to do a week there time and we'd
turn we turn people away when this guy
this critic didn't like my show because
there was a girl down the street that
saying that cabaret music and she would
didn't have anybody and didn't we're
turning people away and he said
basically all I did was like drink my
beer and mumble scratch my head and then
singing off a voice because
damn well she wasn't getting some of the
people that we were turning away so he
wrote this song entertaining there's a
dog back and actually I talked about
this review before his dad's been
retired for years but he's been reminded
before about this but I kept it changed
as my yeah Duke is at those humors yeah
yeah well and you also had another early
review that was Roger Ebert so you play
right here first I was still mailman and
that's what I was saying one day a week
on Thursday and Roger stopped in he
watched I have a movie that he doesn't
like and stopped him to get a bear and
the music room was in the back and
somebody told them I was having that
beer they should go catch this kid
because you know he's really something
and next day Roger took his whole back
pages of sun-times entertainment section
and looked the same no man delivers the
message I never had an empty seat after
that John told the story of being sent
off packing to write the album how did
what were you thinking when you when you
said okay it's time for you to go write
an album well I knew it was time that he
write a record we had just taken over
the record company about about two years
ago yeah and we needed a product you
know we need a new John Prine product
and I knew he had songs because I've
been listening to him for the last
couple of years just noodling around and
doing some co-writing with friends with
Pat McLaughlin I was in the kitchen when
he and Pat wrote summer's end and that
had been two years previously and so I
knew he had songs but I also knew he
needed to get it stuck to him I mean
John's not gonna do it unless it's down
to the wire
it sure is that true when things around
the house as well
waiting for me to fix things around DIY
type person no no no no she probably
think if she saw me with a hammer in my
head I just keep reminding myself he's
an artist he's an artist but he always
has an extra set of silverware so he
does he does and or mustard or ketchup
or maple syrup yeah but Jodi and I we
both knew we needed a record and we knew
that he had one and that we just needed
to get his attention and so you get him
a really nice sweet and a really nice
hotel they're good to make yeah yeah
yeah I could see how you could get
distracted in a room like this if you
were writing sometimes at home yes this
is a pretty nice center here yeah you
tell me it's been just about every
waking hour in this event and that's the
that's where you're watching jeopardy
and jeopardy we're fortune and CBS this
morning that's a good time
listen when I wrote probably probably
over 90% of the songs Oh certainly all
the early songs were written on that
about this Noons 1968 I got Lee Harvey
and December 67 I had Oh
Gibson hummingbird and he'd been dropped
I had to sell it to my staff sergeant so
where the motor pool sergeant because
yeah a country band and he wanted to
play it and the neck had broke off of it
like a couple of times there was a
hairline crack back here but not this
guitar the Gibson I sold it to him and
he tried to get it glued a couple of
times and neck up flying off in the
audience so he gave it back to me cuz I
was original are my golly I mean I
probably homeland sent away and got it
fixed by Gibson and they sent it back to
me and I traded it Martin
this thing was brand-new in 68 this is
what the road would do to you you know
the guitar and I was retired and I'm
still out there saying
you know you could tell you look at it
strange that gets a crack in it this is
from Harlan Howard's first birthday bash
just about 90% of my sounds a certainty
over the first eight hours on this uh
this guitar here and so you would play
that on the road then and yes yes it was
in one guitar no anything else I had it
was always a spare guitar but this is
the main deal and then this one Saturn's
so sweet the more you play a guitar like
this the better it sounds and I played
the heck out of it so there's a lot of
good songs in there anything left in
there what's written on the guitar strap
there that was the fan okay they just
sent me this to happen the strap was
already broken I think they got used
there already so that's why it was so
soft I figure I'd use it again moving on
to a bit of Show and Tell never too
precious with his own material Prine
douve into an archive box of published
and discarded lyrics so John these are
two of the boxes that that's right oh
they haven't seen the contents and these
are these are basically the what the the
scrap material that songs would well
these are these are not archived so
these are two boxes from the archive the
bag of Kleenex and in my word I think I
have boxes of them so there's a lot of
stuff in here that pertains to them this
is from my sister now the archive is now
she listed what's in here but this is
the tree of forgiveness but oh this is
the album this isn't my handwriting this
is a forger for John pride where's that
that's just notes from the studio
let's see this is newspaper cuttings
let's see this is this looks like you oh
yeah yeah I always just get sent down to
the principal because I was repeating
looks like my handwriting my mouse
wearing a fine pen trying to get the
heaven as fast as he can here's a Friday
chasing him and so those are the years
weren't you lose me okay Joe has numbers
on it yeah these were different these
were just different sequences for the
record funders love crazy bone mm-hmm
summers Enron we verb oh yeah so I'm
seeing yourself married except for
little brown mouse no ordinary blue
there's a song I wrote with my good
buddy Keith sax from Memphis finished
lyric Sarah these are you have to dig
down into them to get pieces of them you
know usually by the time I see something
that's got a verse or something as soon
as I see it I just get reminded of and
it comes back into into like fair fair
choosing for the song there's one that
didn't never get never got finished well
no wonder is over this code all day I
shouted hooray turned up the volume
you've turned up the volume erased the
problem no problem writing with volume
from my mind but the question was the
best one just leave the past behind oh
this is very no ordinary blue yeah we
see you leave out the bad parts and
seeing the good part I feel like I'm
falling like I'm crawling
just to keep the peace I know what's
that it doesn't rhyme no wonder I would
this be when you were in the hotel room
does it get to this level I mean there
is this what you I can't tell because my
writing looks the same since third grade
yeah yeah this all came out of the hotel
yeah this was all there and there's not
a black sharpie on black sharpie
I got him everywhere I always carry one
with me yeah this one made the song the
orange moon is rising on the horizon and
he has skirts of my mind I never thought
I'd say that in the song but I did now
I'm committed
you mentioned that you carried around
scraps in your wallet yeah where is that
where the songs start yeah usually this
with a song start and end here and I
usually don't commit to paper until I
think I have either a good part of the
song or the whole song is done lucky
there was Sam stone rose on the mail
route and I just committed it to paper
so I wouldn't forget
right yeah when you described I think
Dear Abby oldest baby in the world
I'm trying to think of some other songs
you've talked about you've been reading
the paper and you something struck you
and you just kind of tore it out and
kept it with you is that a is that a
process you you still do yeah I do not
forget where I put it
yeah and then I'm not surprised that
there's something in here that I haven't
seen sink Toria I have a paper yeah I
see I see things written on napkins
sometimes look at how many pages there
are here in this photo the only one page
written on this old thing gone in the
afternoon oh man well no one never got
written know that's why okay the tree of
forgiveness
but that's a good title yes I tried to
write a song called that couldn't get
anywhere with sorry but put making it a
bar the name of a bar in the song when I
get to heaven and nobody can argue with
me
yeah well the idea when somewhere you
know yeah so Fiona when you do you ever
hear him say something or hear something
through his ear and think you know maybe
I'll hear that in a song some year down
the line I hear that with melodies
sometimes when when you pick up the
guitar yeah and you're you're tuning or
you're just noodling I'll hear a melody
I'll hear something I haven't heard
before that's usually really pretty
yeah I'll ask I'll say is that new and
he ignores me he's afraid of it asking
to write a song there's many times I
don't think I have a idea about even
hire a writer so I mean soon as I finish
one I wonder if that you'll be the last
song is it I'm gonna go to write a song
I don't know anything more now than I
did 45 years ago about right you know it
was just a it's guy I do know that my
attention is hard to yet like and why
just because I got all this this junk
[ __ ] around you know and some of that
juggins have become a good size yeah
and it's it's tough to I don't do it
with any kind of order whatsoever so
this is as close to order as you'll ever
see
yeah in your life archived yeah that's
pretty that's pretty sweet though having
and and is this just this last year is
that what's in these or is this oh we
have our art this is there's a huge
there's eight fireproof lacquers
downstairs with every every album every
project every year of his career yeah I
haven't look I'm afraid to I don't know
it's quite a lot
yeah a winner so if you ever have looked
at any of that stuff though have you
ever thought I don't even know dude does
it come back to you or do you think I
don't even know who that person was who
wrote that no I haven't let's do
something 40 years ago I know if it came
from me or from somebody else
Fiona John talked about family what's he
like as a dad oh the boys adore him he's
just a big softy um when I was telling a
friend just the other day that when the
boys were younger the two younger ones
where they were small eight or nine
years old and Sunday night you know they
were in bed was eight o'clock everybody
quiet school the next day John would
come rolling in from the road 9:30 10
o'clock suitcase full of toys
you know everybody's office at Christmas
morning so I mean I know they they have
really good memories of growing up with
their dad it was a reason for me to go
Beijing toy stores yeah yeah I was 49
when Fiona I have my first boy and like
I said you can't you can't go roaming
through toy stores if you don't have
some of you buy them for it yeah so
every week I come home with suitcase
full of toys the boys are in there on
the bed and Flo's your eyes it was like
Christmas is a week when dad came home
yeah and I'd be like but now it's really
sweet to see them you know they're 23
and 24 and they they both sing my guitar
they both write songs so it's really
interesting they watch and you what's
that like for you to watch that this is
really great really great
the boys ever looked for it they they
took right to it you know you can't
force somebody to play insane you know
so just to let him and they both they're
great just great yeah they both picked
up the guitar and just started playing I
mean there was no
question if could they or would they
would they be able to they just did yeah
yeah did watched it for so long
I never been able to teach anybody you
play the guitar I just figured a lot of
people learn to play the guitar because
they figured when they see me do it very
well and a lot of people pick up a
guitar to play your songs to their kids
I mean that's that's what I did
yeah and what does that like for you
when people talk about you know singing
your songs in their families it's great
because it's a it's the most irons away
for your music to get around I mean that
bad instead of having a hit record 28
managers and other stuff going on and
people here because it's a hit there
must be good so listen to it doesn't
like it people pass my songs on because
they feel like they weren't singing for
their kids and the kids grow up with
them and they're coming to my shows and
now the grandkids are coming to my shows
and they tell me that they they grew up
their household always had one or two of
my songs being either son or played the
record yeah it's a good if there's an
honest way to make this lemon it's a
good idea to later make it yeah we got a
lot of letters from you know from young
people whose parents and grandparents
have turned them on to John's music next
to his lyrical archives and vintage
guitars John Prine collects classic cars
he took the wheel as we drove through
Nashville is my beauty a 99 can't like
the belle who rides like a you can't
like our - I know and you've always been
a Cadillac well since about since I
started making money you know kid life
is like Cadillacs especially the older
ones I'm just fat in 82 with 6,000 miles
I started liking Cadillac ii about 1978
about one my first move down in
nashville about a white Coupe DeVille
and I haven't looked back since that man
been buying cattle makes ever since I
don't buy the new one search they ride
too stiff they make them make them like
to compete with competition cars now you
know they haven't actually had like the
red they race oh yeah yeah is the was
the Cadillac for you was it ever the
kind of thing where you said when I make
it big enough I'm gonna get a Cadillac
no it was after it moved to Nashville in
my mind was well you know you're if
you're a country star - no yeah I have a
Cadillac in a guitar and I just said in
and went down - I think I've met a buddy
that kept me working dealership you know
wife singing one night bar here and he
said come on by the dealership sometime
and that's how I
and there's he saw that white Gupta God
just had to have it I got a red coupe
deville down down in Florida we got a
little house down near st. Pete Beach I
got a red one down there with white
interior in the white top
and where do you find old Cadillacs
online online
yeah so and and luckily the ones I once
I bought they've been really good deals
the engine didn't follow the headlights
fire that didn't take some good cars is
that what you're doing some nights at
midnight when you open your lap I'm
looking at that's the last thing before
I go to bed today I look at all the cars
I've amassed on eBay other things I
bought I bought it probably four or five
cars over the years you know I lied I'll
pull the hammer down just that they were
untrue in the morning so I have to deal
with the guy the next day when did you
feel like you you had not made it but
that you were you were now a
singer-songwriter not not just a mailman
whose greatness on the side almost
actually
when we went committed to start my own
record got me okay I was 81 I mean I
mean I knew that that's what he was
doing 411 during the 70s but there was
something really bothering me what was
bothering me was the major labels I just
it wasn't like I was a constant argument
with him I just didn't think that they
understood what I was doing with my
music cuz I go out in the road me in the
audience for always fiji game that
really was great you know and i go to
the record companies and and I go are
going to studio and to make a record and
they're just laying it wasn't the same
thing it's not what I did for 11 you
know but I wanted to know that's the
part of the reason I wanted to start my
own label was I wanted to know I want to
know everything I wanted to know if I
sold 37 records I mean let me know you
know I didn't want there to be a space
between me and the audience and that's
that's partially why I started started
the record company I started with my
business partner in a long time manager
al Boneta
he managed Steve Goodman to me and Al
just passed it's real sudden about four
or five years ago and that's when we
took over the record company and made it
a family yeah uh-huh
was that a bigger leap doing him
creating oh boy records than it was I
couldn't don't when I was my partner
without hell he had the business savvy
to do that and he'd already there was
Steve Goodman yeah there's a Steve
started his own label like a mail order
thing and I just felt better about what
I was doing because I had a direct
connection to the people that came to
the shows
and that's what I was missing was that
direct connection I felt when I was
playing live speaking of the direct
connection that you that you have what
do you make of it when people say they
listen to your music and like two
reactions I get the most one is people
say it brings them inexpressible joy and
the others say it can make them cry what
what is that how does that make you feel
it's the guy who well I know I really
like I like a good sad song yeah I mean
I'm when I'm the listener I'm sitting in
the club and I've liked the band I
always like a bluegrass banjo or said
mouth our hey player sad but yeah I like
sad songs I love the old country songs
where the guy drags the woman down by
the river and kills her and goes over to
his mother with a bloody t-shirt stuff
like that you know that song the old
home town what did they do to the old
home town why did know is that yeah the
old home town he take he marries a girl
it moves to Charlottesville and then she
leaves him and he tries to go back home
and the town doesn't exist anymore
that's a that feels like that feels like
a good depressing yeah but what does it
feel like when you're the when you're
the author of those songs
I mean well my early songs that I know I
killed off a lot the lead character in
llama socks Sam stone the guy overdoses
the six o'clock news the kid jumps off a
bell Dayton I mean I think I think I did
all that because I was looking for drama
yeah
when there was enough drama real-life
drama going on around me yeah I liked it
was like details and songs I like like
to put like an ashtray in the room
before you started talking about
emotions and songs like put something in
the sound
that everybody could relate to you know
I got an ashtray in my room I got this
and then you go into the characters and
then then the listener is already
connected to the story before even the
story starts right right now they can
just it's an everyday room knick-knack
shelf all this stuff and I think as a
writer that that's kind of draws the
people and when you get to start talking
about emotions in the song between the
characters things that you can't see you
know the listeners already able to
answer it's like a novelist with you
want to set up the whole thing so it's
believable when we talk about stuff that
you can't touch you really you can't see
it but it exists
yeah so when you say God bless this
kitchen said the knick-knack shelf
everybody has had an experience in their
life with a knick-knack shelf they know
there's something hearted such God bless
our happy home you know but instead of
saying you're elevating just say the
knick-knack shop said you know said I
can never remember the life's massage
it's like the ABCs I have to start at
the beginning right other song you
remember the whole thing yeah yeah and
when I sit convalesce is kitchen said
the knick-knack shelf dinner's almost
ready
going wash yourself that song I think
looking back on I still do that when we
opened the show with a nap
just just instead of doing a fast runner
or a Robert I opened with blow free TV
for years but we started to open it with
six o'clock news I think the song I
don't think I had a story there I'm
going to tell I was really an exercise
in detail because the whole song sits up
in real fine detail and then I I think
the story was secondary
now I listen to it that's interesting so
you were you just painting a picture
yeah as opposed to telling a specific
narrative yeah that's really interesting
so when you're songwriting if the first
thing that strikes you is a story you
then say okay I have a story in my head
now I need the grounding detail I mean
do you know - its kind of intuitive to
go that you know okay I can't really
think I don't think about songwriting if
I'm writing with somebody else it makes
more sense to talk about like that but I
never know where I'm looking for when
I'm writing by myself I'm waiting for
that one thing I could put my finger on
her touch you know and that everything
else would come out of that yeah yeah I
have no idea where the ideas for songs
come from some are very real come from a
newspaper article or story somebody's
telling me about something like egg and
daughter night yeah country of
forgiveness that was directly this buddy
of mine sitting in a boat telling me
this whole story about how they used to
wait for the farm girls to come to town
and they were brought there by their
fathers that were selling eggs and he
said that in the fishing but he goes
yeah we used to call Thursday night's
egg and dart night and that was all of a
sudden all the lights went off for me I
mean I was not a fishing vacation and I
was looking for so I said you say that
again and he said it again and I said
man that's gonna be a song
I just got his town wrong the oh you
guys town wrong yeah he wasn't never
been to Lincoln Nebraska help
he grew up in Norfolk Nebraska he didn't
tell me that so after I got the record
hmm well that'll keep him out of trouble
if it can't get traced back to him from
any he appreciates a story do you tend
to see people or you know the stories
kind of spool out for you once you see
some interesting telling detail you know
you said the lights went on it was say a
Godard night to me the idea
I mean that was back there at the house
she works at old boy Eileen one day put
inhaler like like after I cut her but
the record wasn't out yet to see if it
was a real thing and by golly it turned
out to be a real deal it went back to a
covered wagon days when I like a guy
would have a rancher or farmer we had
six or seven dollars and one of them
could cook him you keep the money cook
it he dropped him dust in town over they
get married and they called it a entire
night now guy a guy sent me an essay he
wrote he was from Nebraska hey I knew in
the sticks and he wrote an essay called
Haven dark night and I said this is this
is great I said you've been dictated
nice dog like I was it just my
imagination running away with this
phrase and our night
I read somewhere that that I can't
remember who the musician was but you
came home and told Fiona you have to go
listen to him go put it on in the car
and go driving is there something
different about listening to music while
you're driving yeah because you can't
detach from it you know it's not but
that's what I think the thing a song
sometimes when I'm driving it driving
kind of takes the I mean you have to you
gotta know what your mind you and
everything so you have something you're
doing and that's when the other half of
your mind can go off you know you have
to know you're doing something nobody
ever told me that I just figured out and
one of the things for me is driving a
car yeah it allows you to to roam and
then that's what you were saying about
the mail room - exactly yeah because you
are you're doing something even though
it's a you do the same thing every day
you know like you go down the same
street the reason I say that because
about my third week as a mailman I went
down the wrong Street and delivered the
mail for four blocks both sides of the
street because he addresses for this
thing and then we discovered I delivered
the wrong mail and by that time the Sun
had gone down I had you go back and
knock at every door
while they're eating there and you get
the mail back and hand them the right
mail I got in about eight o'clock that
night I remember always check and make
sure you're in the same street cuz they
all look the same
yeah yeah and you did that for five
years yeah six years six years well to
the years I was it was drafted but there
are counts for
because you're working for the
government right you know it so I can
relate to the these people do them
without checks and I was a mailman I'd
be do you know right now it's about 20
below in Chicago with the wind blow for
those people delivering milk no not
getting a jacket there into two weeks
yeah I saw you you helped feed the TSA
agents yes well that was our son Jodi's
idea he came to me with an S it I
couldn't imagine a better thing to do
cuz those guys all know me by my name
I go out there and the TSA guys are all
shouting over through the security thing
they go where are you going were you
doing a show this week
I saw you in Austin City Limits there
are nice people and they try and put me
through a minimum of a hassle like I go
to the security tech yes I figured what
better thing to do than to go out and
feed them when they're not getting a
jacket it's been a month now we are
they're just coming up to it now what we
did pretty good for Friday night rush
hour just sit here on the left
they're really nice mural of the Carter
Family
on the side yeah and yeah there's like
there's a really good guitar stores in
this town all over the place but this
one is smaller and the real nice people
Nashville just got like this in the last
five years right people come here
everybody they discovered there wasn't
just country music though it's just a
great place to live a hundred people a
week of moving here it's been that way
for years to live as far as music
there's all kinds of music it's not just
country music though guys
it's the easiest place to be a
songwriter I mean in LA you have to
drive now right here you just uh
but everybody bump into you know it's a
songwriter I go to the grocery store
used to come only cuz that's were big
there my pockets were full of cassettes
the girls checking me out was a singer
and the guy bagging the grocer's was a
songwriter
the neat thing was kind of like the
stories about early Hollywood that when
people get off the train say I'm gonna
be a star I met a lot of kids understand
that I ran into him the first day or the
first week they were here I wish him
good luck it by golly
next thing you know they got a hit song
is a songwriter or like five years later
they're singing him somebody's band it
actually happens here did that happen
with Kacey Musgraves I made KC wind my
first measure she had that song burn one
with John pride she wrote that before
she came to Nashville and she here
induced yourself to me there's a show we
do an annual Christmas show called the
whole damn family and she came up to me
I remember meeting her and her
girlfriend they wanted to take me out in
the parking lot to do a joint and I said
I can't I gotta go do a show and she
it's because that girl wrote a song
called burn mom with John fry how much
it here I didn't hear it for a couple of
weeks and I couldn't believe how good a
song it was next thing I know she's
Kacey Musgraves what she's doing great
yeah
I'm rooting for her Brandi Carlile for
those big prizes at the Grammys they
deserve it that they know Casey she
knows what to do a big audience it
wouldn't shake her you know you have to
be ready for that I don't think people
realize that yeah we didn't want that to
be a big star you know for years I heard
the reason the other stuff happened this
last year is because Fiona is my manager
knowing I don't know I can't say no to
her you know my old manager I go are you
kidding me I don't want to do that stuff
I just want to go sing my songs wait for
these guys are getting their job right
again and I go I just wanna write in the
old days are up yeah go upstage I could
change my shirt people wouldn't know me
yeah I do walk through the audience you
know and they wouldn't know me now I
can't go pick up my mail people don't
know I do recognize me now in the street
yeah I've never mistaken you for some
other you know well they they say John
John Hiatt
I think he gets the same thing
you know like anybody's named John John
John
I remember in New Orleans one said I was
there a Mardi Gras ago tumbled out of a
t-shirt shop she bumped into me she went
hey you're John frying I've said yeah
you're right you are finally we parked
at Carter vintage guitars a beautiful
shop in downtown Nashville our day
culminated with a John Prine master
class Walker he owns this place he
worked for Georgia he just created his
own business and he's always got some
sweet sweet Tuesday guitar so watch your
walk they'll try and sell you 143 1943 a
Gibson J 45 things older than me
[Music]
I was still I know about you but I feel
good our story you know even like
amateurs know like 20 times more or they
know at least once on where they grew up
yeah and I go to a guitar store and I'm
sitting there going you know and these
guys are picking out all these things
right I said I think I was
Swigert I were just three fret because I
never go up here there's all virgin
territory but even Travis picking for me
is a real challenge so you know I just
did it over and over until one dad took
the guitar out of the case in my fingers
were just you know my thumb locked into
that steady bass beat
yeah and that's that's the whole trick I
think of Travis figured I can't really I
can't Travis Peggy I just do the the
simple part you know make it look good
cut willing and but whatever you figured
out how to do there and now scores the
people on YouTube who will teach you how
to play like John probably never you're
doing my style is a mistake is where he
lives I make the same mistake agent like
every night and I was trying to pick
like Elizabeth cotton in Mississippi
John Hurt who was a huge influence on
anybody that picked up guitar from the
folk movement that he was sixties you
know Mississippi John Hurt
it just looks and sounds so simple you
think he could do it you know and still
I saw thing John Hurt three nights ago
in YouTube I don't know how he does it
yeah he smiles and sings and his hands
are just gliding across the guitar but
it was it was certainly we they caught
my imagination there with a lot of other
people and I'm it's easy for me to write
a song with finger-picking
then this would just playing rhythm
guitar yeah
you picked up a guitar at 14 your
brother your brother taught you
yeah I got a guitar I was 14 I couldn't
play it until I was 17
me and my brother I mean my buddy who
lived across the street we both got
guitars for 14th Christmas and all we
played was a rebel rouser by Duane egg
and so anything that you play on two
strings we could play yeah and then my
brother taught himself how to play the
guitar and fiddle and mandolin and many
times if I would play the federal he
needed somebody to play rhythm guitar
while he was playing and it sounded
awful I was I was squeaking scoffing
yeah and so he taught me three chords
and taught me to play federal terms and
that's our third plan and right after
that I got my first song really early
yeah but and then did you study folk
music in Chicago no there was at the
school the Old Town School of Folk Music
the reason it appealed to me is because
you didn't have to learn to read music
they would teach you by ear and you
would walk out of there that first week
going into a class there you go home and
you could play a song an old folk song
you know and I would I went there for
about six weeks like one class a week
and the guy was a bluegrass you really
like bloopers music so he would teach
you bluegrass runs and stuff and that
was all interesting to me and then I got
drafted and went away and came back and
I went back to the old town of school
but by that time I could play pretty
good yeah
is there a song when you pick up a
guitar that you always go to that's like
your you know that's your no I just dirt
okay absent mindedly finger pick you
know
[Music]
if I pick long enough I'll go into a
John Pratt's place one from the new
album all right
[Music]
if you like your apples sweet and your
streets are not concrete you be in your
bed by 9:00 every night take your hand
spanked corn-fed gal and your best
friend's four-eyed pal to a treat but
down the street that's dynamite
let your conscience be your guide if you
put your foot inside you wish you left
you will enough alone
when you got hell to pay put the truth
on layaway and blame it on that
Oh crazy bout crazy bout crazy bout
where you wish you'd left you well
enough alone when you guys hell to pay
put the truth on layaway and blame it on
that
Oh crazy bone this is a good part
but don't be stuck up in Alaska last
when you should be in the brass cup on a
Thursday I win it's a game daughter
tonight when the farmers come to town
and you spread them eggs around and they
drop their donors down at the rotor
array
where you probably standing there I wish
you slicked back Brylcreem hair
you're lucky saying you daddy's
fine-tooth comb
if I knew where you were thinking they'd
run you out of Lincoln
I'm just blaming on that Oh crazy bone
crazy bone crazy bone well you must have
left that wisdom tooth at home if it
knew where you were thinking they'd run
you out of Lincoln just blame it on that
Oh crazy bone your gums that crazy bone
deed it at that but I bet Skeeter that
that that I do Skeeter lot by being
laughed at by Babu steel laptop our food
did last night Abu Skeeter life I did
love that I do that I paint scat singing
knew their job yeah that's my shaving
song in the more you went nobody can see
me and I'm looking in the mirror with
shaving cream all over my face actually
I was trying to describe to the producer
of the record a cop who I thought the
horns she'd go on nothing he thought
what he was doing hood back shaving
songs that are better than horns now
here's the morals of the story
where's it going now how do you get back
to it after talk so much
although when your grandkids all are
grown and they put you in our own an
eternity is approaching fast
yeah you're half out of your head and
you probably pissed the bed
and you can't see your thing to save
your posterior you're a win fire across
the Prairie local cemetery Terry they
already got your name carved out in
stone a we know them nurses say clamp
away you walk that way just blame it on
that whole crazy bone and everybody and
that old folks home yeah blame it on
that
Oh crazy bone crazy bone joven piece
there's a song I wrote for my father you
see him and my mother from Burke County
and my dad loved him nothing better than
driving down from Chicago down to
Western Kentucky and taking his boys
down to paradise and we just saw through
his eyes and it was like a make-believe
place - you know
when I was child my family and we
traveled down to Western Kentucky
well my parents were born there's a
backwards hotel thus often remembered so
many times that my memory isn't warm
then you want to take me back to
Muhlenberg and then by the Green River
with Pierre - Lee I'm sorry my son but
you're too late and asking mr. Peabody's
Coltrane is to hold it away well
sometimes we travel right down the green
river to the abandoned old prison damn
buyer here where the air smell like
snakes we shoot with her thirsty but if
he pop bottles was all that we killed
then it won't take me back to you to
Burke County then by the Green River
where Pierre - lay I'm sorry my son
makes you late Nazca mr. Peabody's
Coltrane's
hold it away now we have to do it my
soul that's on you
[Music]
I can't really figure so I just played
loud that's that's a solo then the cold
come became with the world's largest
shovel the torture heard the timber and
the stripped of the manga the duck for
their cold till the land was forsaken
then they routed it all down there's a
progress of man they won't you take me
back to Newton per County down by the
Green River where paradise lane I'm
sorry my son but you too late nasty mr.
peepers Coltrane's holiday away
I'll save everybody but not playing
another son
[Music]
now when I died with my ashes float down
the Green River I let my sober on up but
to the Rochester dam I'll be halfway to
heaven with para - wait just five miles
away from whoever I am they won't take
me back to me lumber camp and I'm mad
the Green River where Pierre - Lee I'm
sorry my son are you too late and asking
mr. Peabody's cold traders oh yeah oh
man you sound pretty good I did was just
grow up listening to John I would sing
that song to my kids
Oh ready to write when they were little
babies to put yeah wait coz they didn't
wouldn't go to sleep so I had to sing
them songs and so I just worked my way
through the through the John right John
Prine songbook but paradise was always
always in there yeah I was like sitting
in that snow my dad loved that song cuz
he was in it yeah you want him to know I
was a songwriter that's part of the
reason I wrote that song the one I
wanted him to connect to the song cuz he
always liked me to sit in the kitchen
and sing uh Hank Williams senior songs
Foreman well he kept songs and Stephanie
and I wanted to know that I could do
that too you know so I wrote Paradise it
was his story and then my Mexican home
in the last verse is about Eve every dad
you dare in the front porch sitting
there watching the cars go by
yeah and you you'd been with him earlier
that day I had that was that regalia
army and I was sitting talking with him
on the porch and then I said like I was
I was married and I left moved our house
and lived across town I said I got going
down he said what stick around and talk
some more you old man you know I didn't
know I'd never seen him again
and so I wrote that song I filled in
there yeah it's a beautiful song